okay now thankfully for you guys the
only log functions were ever interested
in different shading are the ones with
the natural mesh okay which is just as
well for you because the other ones are
a mess do be wary though on your
calculators if you've got them there
okay
you've got two buttons for large right
you've got this button more and then
you've got probably one next to it which
says LM right okay now she's very care
to really get it easy on your calculator
and early on your calculator this means
log base 10 okay which is why I think if
you look above this button okay I think
I would say 10 to the power X okay
because that button is really about
scientific notation they'd help you out
with your you know the chemistry stuff
and working out concentrations or
whatever you do for titration I don't
know I never did constrict but that's a
lot base 10 okay overly on your
calculator everywhere else you see
there's the word logarithm if you see it
in the textbook if you sit in the exam
if you see it on my board what we really
mean is log base E because that's the
important one okay so what we really
mean is this okay so if you ever seen
log in an exam please don't press if
your log button on your calculator cuz
it's eternally different base what we're
really after is this one okay
all right now that was my preamble let's
have a look back at different changes
they okay you remember so many questions
in maths boiled down to trying to turn a
problem that you don't know how to solve
into a problem that you do know how to
solve and then you work with it okay so
what could I do to this equation
the change into something that looks a
little more familiar yeah this is a
logic later and logs and indices I'm
really just pops the sides so if I were
to rewrite this I would say X is equal
to even what is that okay this is very
very very similar so what I have over
here right except it's just a different
variable now because it's just a
different variable instead of working
out do idea
which is what I have when it's like y
equals something I'm gonna work out D X
on dy these letters I can just switch
them do idea it's just a fraction just
like any other okay so when I
differentiate it I'm differentiating e
to the Y reads respect to Y now you know
all these questions they just put you
from that is in there like s squared
plus s differentiate with respect to s
or differentiate with respect to T
whatever they're just letters okay so
when I differentiate this it follows
exactly the same rules as it is the
other difference is in sublime so what I
get is now what I was really after right
was luck DX or dy I want dy on yet and
we said this is just a fraction right so
if I've turned this side upside down
I've taken the reciprocal then I should
take the reciprocal the other side all
right yes that make sense
one will step either way right even why
is actually just X right that was the
substitution that I made
so therefore this derivative is 1 over X
so get M cannot get read and put some
big boxes around these two results a DX
you differentiate it you get its back
log X maybe I should put that out front
the derivative of the natural log is 1
over X ok now let's just think about
that first time let's uh you know is
that some Placid intuition okay what
does the log function look like okay it
only exists for X is greater than 0
right and it's like an exponential
that's just been twisted over now how
would you describe its gradient well
it's kind of an opposite it's this
gradient it's kind of the opposite the
exponential one right it's always
increasing it's monotonically increasing
but instead of getting faster and faster
and faster it's good the slower and
slower and slower okay so that's what
the great it looks like well let's think
about what this looks like 1 over X do
you guys know what whatever it looks
like you've been graphing out for years
what does it look like over here looks
like this doesn't it at least on this
side okay that's exactly what we've got
number one this gray is always positive
and that corresponds to the fact that
this graph is always increasing okay
number two keep the gradient is getting
smaller and smaller smaller forever okay
which corresponds to the fact that long
X is getting slower and slower and
slower forever does that make sense